i am thrilled to be sitting here with
one of the coolest guys in the world one
of the best snowboarders in the world
louis vito thank you where do your
people hail from italy italy yeah do you
ever say it
louis veto i asked him where his people
hail from
if you're on a half pipe yeah and you do
this move
then you're here
what you probably call in the pocket
uh in the transition
in the pocket from here on out when
you're here you'll go i'm in that sweet
sweet powder pocket well there's no
powder in the half pipe i know where the
powder is not in the half pipe or the
pocket
i didn't come here
to have you tell me where the powder is
do you have a reckless tooth
sometimes in the right situations i get
pretty reckless with my dude
every year it says here
you hold an event what is what is it
called uh louis vuitto rail jam it's a
charity event at my home mountain in
ohio the rail jam yeah
sounds like the movie i tried to run my
hotel last night
i heard your mom owns a jazzercise
company yeah she owns like a part of the
judge like she has a judge-sized
franchise
a jazzer chaz yeah you should do it yeah
right after i kill myself you don't like
exercise anything earth size is bad
what's something you love sex is
exercise i'm out
really yeah i don't want to exercise you
just lay there like the dead fish
you've seen rail jam
louie i've heard that the olympic
village can be like a weird kind of
breeding ground for us that's what i
hear too so you didn't get wild at the
olympic village not in that aspect you
didn't do anything
rail jamming no yep we kept that on the
mountain stay dusty and crusty
stay reckless stay with your dude with
your dude your dude thanks for being
here louis vito
thanks for having me